[Musique]
après la série de vidéos sur les
conseils sur la meilleure façon de
préparer son festival on est venu voir
sur place pour hellfest comment ça se
passe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'avoir le niveau 2
ces reports sur le hellfest c'est quoi
exactement où nous avons 70 secouristes
qui sont répartis en deux postes de
secours ok donc un poste de secours sur
le site qui est ouvert pendant les
heures de fait de concert bien entendu
et on a
un poste de secours au camping pour nous
le mercredi midi pour les premiers
arrivants qui sera ouvert 24 heures sur
24 jusqu'à lundi midi c'est ce que
risquent à sont épaulés par des médecins
et des infirmiers le festival et qui
vient ici faut qu'il soit pris en charge
et qu'ils puissent retourner dans la
mesure du possible
profitez des conserves si on l'envoie
sur deux sites hospitalière c'est en
comble et les hôpitaux
et en plus ils perdent une journée de
festival donc achever ce valet
exactement donc
on arrive à voir des médecins qui
peuvent structuré qui peuvent gérer les
luxations de base plus beaucoup d'autres
choses que des secouristes ne pourrait
pas faire donc est ce qu a pu être
transporté par une ambulance vous ça
permet de garder les festivaliers de
resto le festival du coup ils sont pris
en charge ici et en quelques dizaines de
minutes qui peuvent retourner sur le
festival
pour conduire leurs week-ends et du coût
en terme de nombre de passages sur les
différents postes de secours hier des
relations secouriste sur les années
précédentes ça donne ça donne quoi alors
ça va dépendre des années ça dépend
beaucoup des températures sur la tâche
et france en tête ont une centaine en
plusieurs centaines on dépasse le
millier et donc en ondes au nombre
d'évacuations en nombre d'évacuations
l'année dernière je crois qu'on était à
peine une dizaine donc ce qui est pour
le public plus le personnel qui
travaille et les bénévoles
c'est dérisoire c'est à dire des
médecins justement on évacue quasiment
personne
c'est quoi la les plus
motif de
d'intervention des secours le plus
fréquent c'est quoi le malaise le mal
alors j'irai même pas forcément
éthylique
attention parce que c'est une vieille
légende aussi malaise qui lie coup il y
en a mais les gens ils sont souvent en
bandes dont ils gèrent leurs copains qui
en fait un malaise et eric ne s'est pas
forcément à cette hauteur des gens qui
viennent là c'est pour des traumas bénin
entorses foulures est ce qu'on veut
petit malaise dû à la chaleur d'une
mauvaise alimentation ou pas une
alimentation du tout une allergie à
parce que ils sont allongés à la pelouse
ils ont répliqué par des bestioles
voilà des petits trucs ouais ouais on
est vraiment très peu de 2
de trauma grave très pour tordre le cou
aux légendes et histoires de bagarres
n'y en a pas en fait part très
clairement mais bon ça il ya que les
gens qui sont dans ce milieu là qu'ils
le savent les métalleux renvoie cette
forme de violence cette image des
violences par le look les tatouages ou
piercings la musique aussi qu'est qui
envoie cette impression de violence mais
le public lui voilà à prendre à des
brebis galeuses
bien sûr on a quelques départs de
bagarre mais très clairement l'année
dernière j'ai entendu à la radio un
départ de bagarre
donc qui a été réglée par les
festivaliers eux-mêmes à part ça non
niveau bagarre mais nous on sait très
bien les erreurs les plus souvent
commises par les sollicitations massif
déjà way et ensuite à l'endormissement
au soleil
santos monnaies comme ça où il fait bon
avec le petit vent frais y fait bon sens
en dehors au soleil ça va brûler et on
arrive avec des gens qui ont des
brûlures premiers deuxièmes voire limite
des fois
troisième de l1 qui dérouille vraiment
pas qu'ils se protègent pas en plus
j'aime pas la plupart se protègent pas
c'est pour ça que votre petite chaîne
avec les petits conseils de crème
solaire toute la journée je valide alors
si vos copains de rien
[Musique]
bon moi je vous ai donné mes conseils
mais les festivaliers ils en ont
sûrement aussi pour vous
mais
[Applaudissements]
pas du tout alors c'est quoi ton petit
truc pour qui conseille pour le match 2
contre aces autocollants pour lui ceux
qui ont les cuisses les frais d'un jour
concrètement il demande des réponses à
ces noms tous est allé crème aussi
décret sur les allées jean qui pour le
moral car aussi le déodorant bihan titre
aspirants et en mai un peu avant tu es
sécher si c'est miraculeux
merci google la petite poche d'eau
on a fait le deuil nous de la semaine
dernière et à la petite poche d'eau à 10
euros franchement le sac c'est le stade
chabou pas exact bah oui ça c'est une
bonne idée que les points d'eau c'est
vrai que c'est compliqué surtout
beaucoup m de crème solaire
ouais moi depuis que je me suis fait
tatouer sinon bah c'est à essayer quand
même voir de la flotte de temps en temps
[Rires]
voilà super chaude et sèche comment
travailles-tu
mon bord de l'eau à ses châssis
le baume à lèvres à moi j'achète pour le
coup j'ai vraiment pas pensé
ce matin je me suis réveillé j'avais
deux cracotte à la place de de la rue
basse instant de ce fait mais animé par
le soleil mais vraiment possible
d'apprendre des
qu'est ce genre prend vraiment pour les
concerts et spéciaux avec les filtrer
tout parce que sinon on n'a pas le
mensonge honteux première fois qu'on a
ce demander
dans le dessin d'une foudre rcnm
suppléante l'autre on a la bonne musique
les bons temps et tous les experts
nickel premier en trop bonne idée j'irai
surtout ne rien ne pas oublier des trucs
pour la nuit parce qu il fait super
froid même s'il fait chaud la journée et
toute la nuit
cai amor mag les sacs de couchage et
tout ça quand ils n'ont vraiment pas à
oublier de prendre un sac de couchage
des pulls lettre comme ça
la nuit s'attendent la température est
bonne mais j'ai tout acheté de la bio
finnova qui conseille fraîcheur c'est
quoi petits conseils précieux en
l'utilité du geek très bien très bien
avec ou sans quelques sous sol où
l'utilité du bolide est monté dans la
kingdom à cruscades elle a vite fait de
prendre un peu de concerts sous la
je suis ta leçon de qui ces pratiques
l'épisode
il en redistribue pas dans la poche des
pétitions n'est pas inclus a vraiment
plus de trucs pour pour pisser quand tu
es un mec
ouais en plus t'es pas obligée de
t'asseoir donc correctement de choper
des saloperies alors que le pied de nez
ça en fait pour la préparation et
farceur des squats à quoi ça passe pas
ou peu s'hydrater sont traités les uns
les autres et puis surtout bas
profitez-en ce sera très bien oubliée
[Musique]
on sait comment est ce qu'on sait si on
est déshydratée et bien le meilleur
moyen le truc le plus simple c'est de
checker son pipi s'il est trop foncée si
sur le potage c'est vous n'avez pas vu
assez d'eau parce que avec l'alcool et
la chaleur on se déshydrate hyper vite
donc chez qu'est votre piscine
voilà l'ol et d'été fait c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là mettez
vous bien et surtout portez vous bien
[Musique]